the Joe Rogan experience Rand Paul's an
interesting cat I like him
well I was uh I want to talk to his
neighbor that [ __ ] him up that's such
a [ __ ] move does such a [ __ ] that is
such a [ __ ]
tackled him when he wasn't even look I
know yeah I think he had earphones on
too that's it's it's a I don't know I'm
not sitting here like some bad ass but
come on what the [ __ ] you're doing
yeah how about that guy that kicked
Arnold Schwarzenegger yes he kicked this
kid dress Donald Swardson I think he was
crazy
South African he was saying he was
screaming out help me I need a
Lamborghini while they're arresting him
[Laughter]
it was the bat sauce WorldStarHipHop
he's on look I mean if that's what we
want
what really happened it to Arnold
nothing what's really gonna happen to
that kid actually I don't know you don't
know South Africa it's look at look at a
Ottawa beer in North Korea he steals a
sign of easy and so it we don't know
what the laws like in South Africa could
he think it's not as bad as North Korea
it's not as bad as North Korea come on
[ __ ] them up pretty well do they look
like it yeah two seconds listen if
you're if you're drop kicking people out
of nowhere that's the problem when I was
talking to Eddie Izzard yeah Eddie ran a
bunch of marathons in South Africa 20 it
was it was - it was a designation it was
the same number as the amount of years
that Nelson Mandela was in prison so
it's 27 so he ran 27 marathons but there
was areas where they're like listen man
you ain't running through here like this
is this area you won't go to we're gonna
take you we're gonna put you in a car
we're gonna drive you way the [ __ ] past
here and then you keep running you're
not running through here like you'll get
killed
yeah yeah you get you get carjacked this
is we're all gonna get shot you're not
going through here and that's you know
there's parts of the world that are like
that and Armin Schwarz and Edgar when he
visited South Africa what's the worst
you got dropped kicked in with poor
technique okay I want to say the kid had
no follow-through right right barely
knocked a 71 you first of all even
though Arnold Schwarzenegger 71 years
old he's still a 71 year old Arnold of
course he's still a tank but I mean even
in fall over
drop yeah he didn't even know it was
coming right he gets hit in the middle
actually just [ __ ] and it is fine it's
kind of impressive